hello I come with a message from the
future I have seen terrible things
things that no one should see I'll come
to warn you this video while it doesn't
contain these things shows me reacting
to them you will not be subjected to the
things that I have seen don't go looking
I'm gonna do this I'm gonna do this
challenge gonna scar myself for Life
hello everybody my name is Markiplier
and welcome to reddit's 50 50 Challenge
and if you don't know what our 50 50 is
it's a subreddit that has a 50 50 chance
of giving you two outcomes you either
get something cool funny or sexy maybe
or something that's going to
horrifically scar you for life like the
don't laugh challenge I act as the
filter the raw uncontained horribleness
in this video
strained because it filters through me
the brave ones of you can go to the
website which I will put in the
description and try for yourselves but I
warn you it's gonna get bad
real bad okay anyway hell yeah I am a
man and I have no feelings
bear monkey or pregnant woman oh it's
the hilarious paramedic monkeys
oh they're cute oh they're cute oh they
forgot them oh that's good okay oh
that's cute oh that is good I like that
oh that's good okay all right so we made
it through the first one yeah put a
score up on the Markiplier scoreboard
put one up for the hoorays team hooray
and then team
that's a team and none and of itself and
then
Mexican drug cartel beheading or a
volcano rabbit I don't know I don't know
what that means it's a volcano rabbit
and that's that's
what a volcano rabbit was okay we're two
for two baby seal clubbing or adult seal
clubbing oh it's literally it's
literally seal in a club oh that seal
right there I have a funny feeling that
I may have organized this poorly Harry
prolapsed anus or an oddly shaped kiwi
fruit that is an oddly shaped kiwi fruit
that is a very I think we need to censor
that kiwi fruit that's no good at all
we're doing great but I've sorted them
by top rating and I I may have failed to
understand that maybe the good ones got
rated up higher so it might be biased
but I'm gonna I'm gonna try a few more
before I before I I get done here
adorable kitten likes his bow tie or man
trips on Railroad train runs over him oh
I've been doing oh it's so good I don't
want to play the bad version I like this
version Oh I like it I don't wanna I I'm
seeing all these cute things I don't
want the bad ones world's first flying
ostrich is dead or UK couple on fire on
cast
oh
[Music]
yes did they Taxidermy an ostrich into a
into a drone oh I like this so much
better I don't want the bad ones hot
OverWatch Mercy cosplay or penis caught
in bike chain oh it's lovely oh that's a
great cosplay you're doing good Tina
kins a baby playing with his father or a
baby with Harlequin itchy osis I don't
know what that is oh no oh no that poor
baby oh no oh God
I bleach I bleach please I bleach oh
look at the kitty oh it's a good kitty
oh look at that today's Kitty right
there
oh look at you yeah you can walk you can
do it oh do it oh you're so cute oh how
about bubbles oh
adorable album of an unlikely friendship
between an owl and a dog or surprisingly
disgusting throat cam of people kissing
that is surprisingly disgusting I am
surprisingly disgusted by that oh brush
your teeth oh stop it it's gross oh
that's like a clam oh it's like a big
oyster trying to you know the the video
the oyster trying to lick the salt on
the table that's what this looks like
there's no salt in there you can't
butthole versus wax or butthole versus
laser neither of these seem like a good
try oh no oh no
oh no it's laser butthole
oh God it's laser butthole I have to sit
through this [ __ ] fazura on all
saruga corn oh God it's a butthole ah
um
[Music]
oh why how much of this do I have to
watch I'm not even at the laser part
it's just butthole it's just a lot of
butthole I got a new play-by-play
commentary of this [ __ ] because it's
a butthole let me just say uh they're
prepping the butthole for the laser
right now it's like a medical document
oh now comes the painkiller oh they
didn't they did all this pre-pain killer
oh now oh now you're gonna give him
painkiller in his butthole
oh my God no how is that oh God no oh
okay I'm out I'm out I'm out I'm out
enough enough whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa I
please please
why did I do this one
I haven't even gotten to the really bad
stuff
I'm a gentle soul man I didn't think
this is gonna be bothering me back in
the day I used to go on 4chan all the
time okay I feel ill I just wanna I just
watched a butthole be lasered and then
other stuff happened to that butthole I
don't wanna I don't want to paint a
pretty picture that it was just a story
of a lovely laser and a lovely butthole
on a lovely day and a lovely walk
through the park no it was bad it was a
lot of bad don't look that up it was bad
okay well well we were uh what four five
however many of that number to this
number where
to say Nam so we've got man slowly dying
on the street while another man beats
and impales
or funniest arrest ever oh it's the
arrest oh it's okay
gentlemen this is democracy manifest see
that chap over there got your hand off
my penis
the biker got me on the penis before
and you sir are you waiting to receive
my limp penis pound cake at your [ __ ]
[Music]
that was that was pleasant that was
pleasant that was pleasant okay man gets
into horrific motorcycle accident or man
flips onto car on Highway those could
both end terribly I don't know what it
is
[Music]
oh wow
wow holy [ __ ] that was awesome I mean
horrifying I mean terrifying but holy
[ __ ] I think I legitimately
got into a horrible motorcycle accident
and then flipped onto a car little foot
injury or ten pitbull puppies
my god
oh
that one was like morbid but I don't
know why I kept looking at it why did I
keep looking at it ah
girl eaten alive by toy or girl eaten
alive by lions
foreign
I know you should feel bad you should
feel bad man removes large tonsil stones
ew or puppy removes large bone it's
tonsil stones ah
oh my oh I'm not okay with this uh
I'm gonna Pew good God ew
Ewa
[Music]
no is that in my mouth
is that in my mouth
[Music]
okay all right you know I'm out I'm out
no I don't want a before and after [ __ ]
you colorblind child seeing colors for
the first time or playing with tendons
[Music]
oh is that person alive oh it's like a
medical examination table they're
pulling out a dentist in his arm oh my
God hips don't lie or fingertips sliced
off cause you know these are too related
items oh good it's the hips not lying
thing those hips are truth tellers you
put them in a court up on the jury stand
judge juries Judy Judge Judy's
it's cross-examination stand also known
as the witness stand they're not gonna
lie hyena loves belly rubs or
lion bites off the penis of a buffalo
oh God no lion don't do that
I mean I get nature and all that in it
because killer be killed in the jungle
I think I'm done oh I think I'm done
how'd he die please thank you thank you
that's good at least can I get this full
screen please
please [ __ ] okay
okay
well that went well I skipped over some
of the potentially worse ones just
because I didn't even want to mention
them to you guys but this is a challenge
that is
really freaking hard to get through so I
will leave it at that thank
you for watching
a fun adventure I know
this if there ever is an actual
challenge to be deemed a real challenge
it's listen
and my advice don't go looking for these
because it's not good so anyway thank
you everybody so much for watching let
me know what you thought down in the
comments below and once again remind
each other this I bleach is available
but do not go hunting for that which you
do not want to see it will only bring
you sadness so thanks again for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video
bye-bye
[Music]